[Music]
don't talk to me before I've had a sip
of coffee the last person you talked to
me before I had coffee
don't touch me before coffee but missing
some people are scared of me but
whatever a drink should be refreshing it
should be like a cool refreshing drink
Matt I'm a mouth's on fire when it's hot
I can walk around with my iced coffee
and no one will judge me and when it's
cold people are like what are you doing
I love it
so I drink my coffee black no no sugar
no milk no pro I just go to work spray
clean zero games on my phone you know
what I do I read news that's it
I know everything about coffee I am like
the coffee connoisseur sommelier so
coffee is not easy it's not simple I've
been studying the art of coffee for 17
years now so we require all of our
suppliers to pick the beans by feet just
taste you'll notice that once you once
you develop the the coffee palate
typically roasting just in my experience
destroys the flavor of the bean so we
toast here yeah
hi I'm entries have an iced grande iced
coffee no classic a little bit of
half-and-half I mean you have people say
I'm a coffee addict but you know I read
the New York Times like they say it's
fine like no one's proving anything
wrong with coffee I think anything's
wrong with coffee I again I screw in the
iced coffee no classic with a little bit
of skim milk so that five sounds about
normal a day I mean this is I'm up to
three so I think I can go up you know
five is a good stopping point barista
regular yeah I'll probably cut off
around five
I'm more of a flow easygoing person and
I'm just not trying to be off the top
all the time I mean yeah a lot of older
people drink decaffeinated coffee but I
mean I guess I'm kind of like an old
soul myself I don't need help staying
awake and I enjoy resting I mean isn't
that normal I never miss a night's sleep
not with this I love coffee but I don't
want to over pollute my body hi I want
an almond milk latte how many calories
is in that one for me it's really
important that the milk is organic
almond milk soy milk hemp milk I'm in
the process of trying to cleanse my body
right now so I don't want to pollute it
with other unhealthy sugars I can I have
a large french vanilla coffee with lots
of skim milk and three sugars so I like
the idea of coffee but I need to have a
lot of milk in it and a lot of sugar cuz
they don't love the taste of it actually
can it just be more of like a milkshake
just a little bit of coffee in it like a
drop it is not enough milk let's pour
out half of that I love coffee but no
more because I've been getting a lot of
headaches and stuff I'm trying to quit
coffee it's been surprisingly hard if I
was drinking coffee still which I'm not
tea I really like like Rose actually
because you don't know this and it's not
kind of counterintuitive but a light
rose scent have more caffeine in them so
you were getting more bang for your buck
me know I I don't miss coffee if
anything coffee misses me
what are you drinking see you're
drinking tea what are you even doing
this coffee shop get out here